that's like a big thing for me is I need
to make men obsessed with me I need to
have that power over them um no matter
how many men I make obsess with me the
whole will not [__] fill I was so
mean
like just like on like just so mean for
no reason
I think uh a lot of um it's really hard
to place anger oh if you don't remember
who this girl is I don't we covered her
she was the one who uh made that uh
false claim against Hassan
I think my brain is fine
I'm just impulsive I'm just impulsive
and [__] I'm like I'm I'm obviously
severely mentally
illness
and said that he was going after
underage people and now she tried to
walk that [__] back
when the dude bent over and said he
passed
wait what this is she said she went on
this date with this dude they were
flirting they went back to his place and
then I and then I made a and then I I
made like a joke about it my first video
was like LOL that one time when like uh
this like La comedian like kind of
forced me to eat his ass when I was like
pushing against him lol
um and it was just like a funny video
funny that's really extreme dream this
might be a bit [__] up but like I feel
like eating ass has got to be one of the
hardest things to force someone to do
okay
oh my god there was a lot of pressure on
my head
it was like keeping my mouth full and
making sure that he was not making eye
contact with me so I couldn't say no
like it was very weird and basically she
was eating them from the back and then
she went home and I kept thinking to
myself do you know how hard it is to
force someone to do something for you
while you're on all fours
and leave behind you and these prayer
I'm sorry my [__] I'm just saying
listen if you want me to do something to
you [__] you better not give me your
back give me give me give me your money
[Music]
where your money at
[Laughter]
give me your money
get it yeah put it in the pocket put it
in the back pocket yeah you scared while
the guy is like screaming oh yeah
he was being very menacing sorry
[Laughter]
so yeah she did that we called around on
that and then now you know this is what
she had to say about I like it okay
because it feels like um
a lot of the like outward vitriol was
from people like Abba right who were
like glav or like his audience who were
like flabs so it's like for some reason
I'm like not mad at Steven okay I'm like
well it's not him
it's not him
that's what he's saying he's literally
explicitly saying that too it's not me
yeah and so now I'm like [__] yeah but
which like still obviously so when
people are calling you out on your [__]
and they're like [__] you because you're
falsely accused someone of some [__] and
you back pedal and there's no
consequence to what you do they can't
know they cannot dare to say [__] you to
you but you're gonna be for them
yeah [__] you [__]
you
roll it editor is going to have a lot of
censoring yay whatever it is what it is
how about you get all the [__] out of
the way [__] you
I think I'm done
[Music]
it's like really strange to have this
like anger that like I can't place this
like sadness that I can't place Abba's
like the big one for me and I know it is
Steven
but Abba's like
Ava was so mean
like just like
[Music]
why are you so mean Emma was so mean my
dick ain't never been harder
falsely accuse someone
[__] are you high Abba's like the big
one for me I am the big one
is that a lame dad joke sure is all
right let me just enjoy this one enjoy
it I was so mean
like just like on like just so mean for
no reason
oh City she said what
I think sometimes there's some pretty
women out here who think like life is
supposed to revolve around them they can
be out here destroying everyone else's
lives and their only focus is how do I
feel what am I going through right
that's why when this whole thing was
happening you know who she said was most
suffering from this whole incident cue
violence her husband oh [__] why because
he was being unnecessarily dragged the
innocent person no no boo-boo you're the
one who started a tornado turns out you
also turned on Friendly Fire and [__]
up his home too that's your problem I
don't feel bad for your husband no I
don't feel bad for anybody who
Associates with you nope you
[__] want to harm other people
when people say hey you're harming other
people that's [__] up you want to be
like but my feelings for no reason
because I couldn't watch most of that
video most of the video he made yeah
Abba so three weeks after this
conversation Abba made an entire video
uh
just attacking you
and then and this whole this whole
narrative started around me being like
a liar that's what apparently we made up
the whole narrative that she's a liar is
that right okay let's see
sometimes I be talking
and a lie just
bro bro
we made up what
yo this is like the red pillars who like
the Matrix no [__] that's you the same
way that's you out yourself snitching on
Tick Tock for attention dang that's you
rewind bro yeah roll it back
sometimes I'll be talking
and a lie just he
and I'm like girl
did you really just
we didn't mean that
that's not real sense
this guy was [__] with underage women
girl that's not true
oh my God girl you say You Lie
you say you do that often that makes you
a liar
if I cut meat once
I cut meat if I do it often I become a
butcher that's you
you a liar hold that L sometimes put
your phone down it's gonna be a minute
sometimes go ahead people out there we
have to stop glorifying a couple of
words
oh these are haters sometimes they're
not haters
sometimes what you do is garbage
and they don't like what you do and
sometimes people are not attacking you
it's not because you don't like what
someone is saying that they are
attacking you okay
you said yourself that you lie girl we
didn't mean that's you
stop that was not an attack if you did
something messed up just say I did
something messed up and move the [__] on
move on this whole narrative started
around me being like
a liar that's what everyone says I'm
just like this [__] I'm gonna mute you
yeah I can feel you starting to slip
don't
don't explain yourself don't argue
who's this guy
what the [__] is this guy hey my dude
who the [__] is this guy who
the enabler who the [__] is that dude
I'm gonna mean because you're about to
slip you know you're about to slip in
your truth you're about to you know
unravel yourself who the [__] are you
who the [__] is this guy hey my dude who
the [__] is this enabler hey hey girl
I'm just trying to protect you I'm just
trying to protect your origin who the
[__] is this guy hey you don't want to
know let's just keep let's let's I'm
about to mute you no let her go home
bruh hey bro I think this [__] short he
said what the hell she has to say it's
her dad
what the [__] did you say to me
apparently there's like some weird
incest stuff going on too
slowly like low-key sympathize with her
because the stuff that's going on is
really weird
it's her dad
and like they'd be talking like flirting
and stuff is weird you didn't feel the
dad energy coming from him
you didn't feel it though I could feel
energy but she's at the actual death
wait what energy did you feel
thank you
no
no you can't skip that [__] yeah we
can't bro we can't even go let's go
let's get past it no no no no no you
can't because that explains everything
what you mean
that is protecting her trying to [__]
her and everything and stuff about
everything that never held her
accountable my dad would be like okay I
think a dad would if he's trying to bang
his daughter
still feel like this is like all my
fault
this
everything happens for a reason maybe I
don't know but
that's a weird way to justify you lying
you making an accusation everything
happens for a reason yeah [__] you
utter the words
I just think like if I would have just
shut up
[Music]
[Applause]
I've been trying to tell you that for a
month yeah that's right if you just shut
the [__] up [__] yeah yeah shut up oh I
got a false accuser shut up
sometimes I'll be my mother shut up you
don't have to lie you don't have to fall
asleep you decided to open your [__]
truck but nobody asked you for [__]
nobody nobody [__] we're
chilling at home and then they looked on
the internet and said oh Hassan's need
to underage go shut up how old is this
girl
24 25 she looks 37 but that's besides
the boy she didn't got tick tock in that
Tick Tock yeah she looks I mean lip
injection and [__] like that we'll do
that to you whatever I won't put one
last clip
and I want you guys to understand the
pathology why would someone do this I'm
going to show you guys why so this is
Hassan reading the DMS that she this
girl had sent to him a while back I
think we accidentally met in 2018 while
you were on a FaceTime with bleep I feel
like I'm not making this up it was brief
I haven't even an ounce of I haven't
even announced as hot as than I am now
so you're off the hook if you don't
remember this is her texting another uh
popular streamer
um her name is Destiny she she texts me
out of nowhere December 14th 2021
watching her stream feels like I'm
watching my history teacher teach a
lesson in a very naughty way or maybe
like a really passionate government
teacher either way I'm wet that was her
that was her first form of text message
me on December 14 2021. mind you this
girl has a fiance
now why is she doing all this why does
she do all this listen to her that's
like a big thing for me is I need to
make men obsessed with me I need to have
that power over them um no matter how
many men I make obsess with me the whole
will not [__] fill why are you so
mean
I want you guys to understand the
mindset of these kind of loony bins okay
they're Looney bins I like that that's
exactly what it is it won't it's always
like it's always another it's always
there's always another guy that I have
to make my project and there's always
another person I need to make obsessed
with me it will not fill my whole life
I'd spent uh you know being like Oh if I
find the perfect man who loves me
um everything will be okay he'll save Me
For Myself and then I found the perfect
man and I'm like oh [__] I'm still I'm
like [__] I still feel it so what that
tells me is it's an internal issue and
so I'm just like I'm just sublimating it
some people crave that attention crave
that kind of validation that they'll do
anything
Marcus like she said they got a full
hold they gotta feel and then and then
you're not the one you do you're by you
calling her out you're doing the exact
opposite of what she craves and that's
why it hurts her
she's doing the you're doing the exact
opposite of what you want men in certain
position to do with her and you're doing
the exact POS opposite like being hey
you did this you did that that swack and
you're a liar when you did that you put
yourself in a position that you're not
doing that and that's why you were so
mean all these men they're trying to be
obsessed with me and then there's this
guy one guy that's not buying it and
he's so me and that's why you're mean
right we at least wanted to put this
together for you guys so you guys can
hear yourselves let us know what you
think anything else you want to say
no you're good I'm good I don't need to
say much else she's crying again her
husband's crying I don't give a [__]
this whole idea of a human uh no no you
want to falsely accuse people you get
[__]